after going through many of these Indian
Institute of Technology joint entrance
exam problems I realize that there are a
lot of problems but they really just
expect you to know something so that's
what I'm going to cover in this video
one of those things that they just
expect you to know and what we're going
to do is come up with the relationship
between a conic section in particular a
hyperbola is what we'll focus on and a
tangent line we've done this in a
previous problem but that wasn't in the
general case so let's just have let's
say we have a left-right opening
hyperbola so it'll have the equation x
squared over a squared minus y squared
over B squared is going to be equal to
one and so if I were to draw that
hyperbola it would look something like
this
that's the x-axis that's the y-axis and
then it opens to the right I can draw a
better bottom half it opens to the right
and it opens it opens to the left and in
case you're curious this point right
here if you said Y is equal to zero this
point right here is a comma zero and
this right here is negative a negative a
comma zero so what I want to do is
figure out a relationship between these
a A's and B's and the equation of a
tangent line so let's say I have a
tangent line that looks something like
this let's say it's tangent only at that
point right over there and so it would
look like let me draw a little bit
better than that it would look something
something like that and let's say the
equation for this tangent line is y is
equal to M X where m is the slope plus
instead of saying B for the y-intercept
so normally we would call the
y-intercept B for line we've already
used the B here in the equation for the
hyperbola so let me just call this C so
the C is a little unconventional this is
going to be the y-intercept so let's see
if we can come up with a relation
between the MS the C's and the A's and
the B's and we can actually this we
already used it in one of the iit
problems and I suspect that the next one
I'm going to do will also use this and
as if y'all have seen a lot of Khan
Academy videos
you know that I always like to prove
things from first principles because in
life you can't just memorize formulas
you won't know where they came from
you'll memorize them wrong you won't
understand what they actually mean but
if you're going to take the IIT je exam
I would recommend this you because I
have appreciation for how little time
they give these problems and if you have
to prove from first principles you won't
be able to approve them so let's just
come up with the relation let me stop
talking or let me stop talking without
drawing so let's just see where they
intersect and the whole insight here is
that they're only going to intersect
they're only going to intersect in one
point so what I'm going to do here is
solve for y squared so over here we can
multiply both sides of this equation by
let's multiply both sides by negative b
squared and so you get negative b
squared over a squared x squared plus y
squared right I multiplied it by
negative B squared is equal to negative
is equal to negative B squared and now
let's add this thing to both sides of
this equation and we get Y squared is
equal to B squared over a squared x
squared minus B squared so I just
rewrote the equation for the hyperbola
and let's also write this in terms of Y
squared and then we can set them equal
to each other so over here over here in
this greenish yellow like color if we
square both sides we get Y squared is
equal to M squared x squared plus 2
times the product of those both terms so
plus 2m C X plus plus C squared so in
order for them to intersect they both
have to be at the same place at some X
and y so we can set this Y squared being
equal to that Y squared and then try to
solve for the X obviously we won't be
able to solve for the X because there's
so many variables we can we can find a
relationship between this a this B this
M and this C so there's only one point
of intersection which by definition it
would have to be at the tangent point so
let's do that so we have M squared M
Squared x squared plus 2
see X plus C squared is equal to is
equal to V squared over a squared x
squared minus B squared and I've done a
very similar exercise to this in a
previous a I tje video but here I just
want to focus just on the most general
case so that we have something that we
can add to our toolkit so let's write
this in terms of a quadratic equation in
X so if we if we subtract this from both
sides we get M squared X we get M
Squared we have M squared minus B
squared over a squared minus B squared
over a squared x squared x squared so I
just that's that term and that term
right over there and then my only just
first degree X term is right over here
so plus 2m C X I'll write it in plus 2m
C X and then finally plus plus we have a
C squared and then we're actually going
to have a plus a another V squared over
there so this is going to be this is
going to be plus C squared plus C
squared plus plus B squared now in order
for this equation to only have one
solution let me write it down this is
going to be equal to is going to be
equal to 0 in order for this thing to
only have one solution the discriminant
of this quadratic equation remember if I
when you do the quadratic equation and
these are completely different so
negative B plus or minus the quadratic
formula b squared minus 4ac over 2a you
are only going to have one solution if
this thing over here
if this thing over here if the
discriminant over there is equal to 0 if
b squared minus 4ac is equal to 0 then
you only have the solution negative B
over 2a so in this situation for the
tangent line you can only have one
solution one X that satisfies this
equation so b so b squared minus 4ac is
going to have to equal 0 in the
quadratic formula these are different
B's and A's and C's
Ones we're using here over here RB our B
is that right over there the coefficient
on the X term so that squared is 4 M
Squared C squared and we're going to
subtract from that minus 4 times a a is
a is all of this business right over
here and just to simplify things let me
make this plus and then multiply this
times the negative sign and it will
reverse the sign so I'll put minus 4
I'll put a plus here times instead of
writing since I have to multiply this by
negative 1 it will now be B squared over
a squared minus M squared and then the C
is this term right over here this right
here is C 4ac C squared plus B squared
and this thing is going to equal 0 if
this line is tangent if we only have if
we only have one solution so let's see
the first thing that we can do to
simplify this is we can divide both
sides of this equation we can divide
both sides of this equation by 4 and if
we do that this becomes I wanted to do
that in black this becomes a 1 so we can
ignore that and then this becomes a 1 so
that's simplified our equation a good
bit and now let's multiply the second
part right over here so we have B
squared over a squared times C squared
that is B squared C squared over a
squared and then B squared a squared
times B squared so plus B to the fourth
over a squared and then you have
negative m squared times C squared so
let me do this in another color so then
you have negative 4 the M Squared
negative M Squared C squared and then
you have negative M Squared B squared
negative M Squared B squared and of
course this is all going to be equal to
0 and we have this M Squared C squared
out front over here M Squared C squared
out here and lucky for us this cancels
with this and what do we have left now
every term here has is divisible by B
squared so let's divide every term by B
squared so this will just become a 1
this will become B to the second power
and
then this will just become one and this
and then let's multiply everything by a
squared just so we get rid of the
fractions so when you multiply
everything by a squared this term right
over here becomes a C squared C squared
this term right over here is just a B
squared and then and then all we have
left and then we have this negative M
squared we're multiplying by a squared
so minus a squared M Squared is equal to
zero or we could add this to both sides
of this equation we get C squared plus B
squared is equal to is equal to negative
is equal to a squared M Squared and
what's really neat about this is we now
have a very simple relationship if we
know the line if we know the line we
have a if we know the equation of the
line right over here we would then if we
know what M and C are we then have an
interesting relationship for a and B if
we know what a and B are we have an
interesting relationship for the
equation of the line and maybe if we
have a few other constraints we could
actually solve for them but we'll
actually take this and use this in the
next IT problem we're going to do